three met office where the warnings are
in effect including a yellow weather
warning for thunderstorms in the east
midlands east of england london and
southeast england south west england and
the west midlands
heavy rain has led to flooding in truro
in cornwall the scottish city of perth
had also been flooded and passengers
have been warned to expect delays across
the region and in comb flurry near
somerset a mudslide led to road closures
with authorities saying they cleared 50
tons of mud a drought has been declared
in yorkshire on the flip side the ninth
area of england to be moved to drought
status sky's science and technology
editor tom clark reports from the river
mall in surrey
in places the river mole looks more like
a gravel track here only a few pools
contain what was a healthy fish
population
the situation's so bad the environment
agency have been forced to wade in
they're using an electric current to
stun the trap fish so they can be
rescued and taken down river where
there's more water we've looked at every
single other option we can see that the
levels aren't going to improve
even though we've just had rain now it's
just not enough and because of that we
then have to go to the ultimate stage
which is removing the fish and rescue
them and moving to another place
despite the rain river levels aren't
expected to recover anytime soon oxygen
in the water is dangerously low for fish
and the temperature's dangerously high
they rescued quite a lot of tiddlers
don't need a bigger bucket and an
absolute monster
all the fish including this 10 or 15
pound pike are rushed into oxygenated
tanks to improve their chances of
survival
rescuing fish is a pretty drastic
measure it stresses them out and
sometimes they don't survive the ordeal
but the ones here on the river mole are
arguably a lot more fortunate than on
rivers up and down the country during
this drought
the river door on the welsh english
border is also desperately low marion
wilding jones is a citizen scientist
measuring pollution levels they were bad
before now they're concentrated by the
lack of water
with our
regular phosphate testing being often 10
20 times the target levels
it's become you know quite distressing
she says more urgent action is needed to
limit sewage and agricultural runoff
into the river the river doesn't have
time
to
to wait it just needs to happen now
the environment agency has long been
criticized for not policing river
pollution well enough
its funding for monitoring has halved in
recent years
it told us it's now investing more and
is requiring water companies to do the
same
this drought will pass but the problems
facing our rivers will take much longer
to solve
tom clark sky news